in five four three two one what's up you
stinky smelly [ __ ] other episode of
the genius brain podcast and you know
like I always said I'd like to bring in
interesting people here people who have
a sudden we talk about [ __ ] that I don't
know anything about so we have a very
special guest want to introduce yourself
hey guys I'm Gigi Gigi yeah what's your
last name moon moon
first off yeah what are you I am half
Korean and Greek Italian my dad's half
Greek have Italian how did that happen
what uh just like crazy so my mom grew
up in San Diego my my family moved from
Korea to LA Holly
when my mom was like 2 and then they
moved from LA to San Diego and when your
mom came here she was 2 years old
super young waster her English is on
point though oh yeah
I mean she's chic even says that her her
Korean is like kindergarten status
that's why she never taught me I'm just
like mom why oh yeah so I mean she's
she's probably like bullshitting because
she always I mean she only speaks to my
grandma in Korean yeah everything and so
yeah but she yeah she she's American
through anthers she grew up you know in
Mission Beach and back I guess back in
like you know the 80s and 90s Mission
Beach was like crazy like yeah
gangs punks you know like all those
kinds of people beating up each other on
the street yeah yeah yeah yeah agent
stuff and so she like ran with that
crowd and she was like pretty badass and
yeah it's funny um she I guess just met
my dad
you know just party that's so
interesting cuz like when I everytime I
hear about an immigrant story I always
hear about the parents who came later on
in their life I rarely meet like Korean
American immigrants that come at that
young of an age yeah so I always wonder
because that's not when the huge
migration of Koreans came again like
literally around I say like late 80s or
early 80s maybe like in this in the late
70s I think that's when a lot of like
Korean migrants came in
I wonder what the reason was for your
mom to come here yeah I'm not sure um
she know she had a brother and sister I
guess it was just you know my grandma
all her sisters and brothers like I
guess I don't know the whole family just
kind of came down here really yeah I
never really asked why they just you
should I should I think yeah I will I
never thought about it so yeah because I
feel like for me like growing up like
i've always i never really found it
really important to ask these type of
things to my parents until i got a
little older right yeah
so just because like when these
conversations come up i never I never
realized like how important my origin
and route is to who you are as a person
so growing up too I never thought that
number one I would ever be with a Korean
girl like being with a Korean girl is
something that just slavery Korean
parents dream the neighborhood that I
grew up in was predominantly black
Mexican or Vietnamese right so just me
being around creepy but Korean people
only happen when I was at home or when I
went to church and I just wasn't
attracted to Korean girls like it just
wasn't my [ __ ] like I just didn't know
enough the only thing I thought about
Korean girls was what my mom was and I
was like oh they're gonna be [ __ ]
annoying 24/7 so I just never kind of
looked into a part of who I was right so
it was it's kind of interesting how I
think that I don't know it's I have very
Korean tendencies and I never thought
that I would be someone who was very
Korean right so even when Muriel first
met me she assumed that I wouldn't know
how to speak Korean
and she also assumed that I wouldn't
know how to read or write Korean because
typically a lot of people my age would
don't know yeah they couldn't like
casually speak Korean and my new my
Korean is not amazing but I can speak to
somebody's parents I could if I go to
Korea I can get around yeah I probably
have the fluency level of like
eight-year-old very very Asian though I
do so you know what it's funny um I just
like you like when I was growing up I
didn't really like I was not in touch at
all with my you know Korean yeah
I was just like I'm Korean like whatever
I didn't really I almost like didn't
want to be you know too Asian you know
it wasn't for any reason I just was like
I just didn't associate with it too much
you know um and it actually wasn't until
I I booked that big bang job the music
video that I did oh you were in a Big
Bang video ah so it was totally random I
was like in Hawaii you know just with my
family and I got a Facebook message like
it was a message request like I had to
go and like just see like if I had any
requests and I didn't even have like a
following or anything I think at that
point and I got a message from a random
guy who you know was American and said
hey you were interested in having you in
a Big Bang music video and at the time I
was like I didn't really know who
BIGBANG was I only knew that who of them
because my cousins you know my Korean
cousins were like super into kpop and
all that and I heard them talk about it
once in a while and I was like this yeah
sure like it seems a little bit sketch
cuz you're messaging me on Facebook you
know totally random and I had my manager
at the time contact him and it was legit
they were like yeah they're filming
their video for loser in LA and what
happened was the director had found my
photo somewhere online and told the
casting people like find a girl that
looks like her that's who I want like in
the lead yeah and they were like why
don't we just find her you know so so
they messaged me and it was like instant
like I just I was like sure you know
they switched my roles around a little
bit and you know finally I went in did
the fitting and just shot it like seems
like a blur now because like I didn't
know how big they were when I did the
video I was like yeah like I was just
totally like nonchalant about it you
know like whatever and then um you know
I went to the set on the day of shooting
and they made me up it was my turn I
shot with top and you know after
afterwards I was just like okay this is
cool you know yeah you know I didn't
know who like any of them were I'd know
who top was I don't know like you know
any of the
and you know I was sitting there
watching some of them film their parts
while I was waiting for you know our
scene to go up and the first time I went
to the bathroom do you like check myself
in the mirror and then as soon as I
walked out the bathroom top walked right
by me and he looked at me and he was
wearing like bright and like neon pink
contacts and I just like and then you
know like okay that's the guy I'm
shooting with and we did the shot in his
sleep great and fine whatever and then I
went home and then you know I just was
like I'm just gonna sit there music like
like why not you know on the drive home
and I was like holy [ __ ] this is [ __ ]
good and then I started like kind of
researching more watching my videos and
I'm like like my mind was being blown
and like like oh my god you know like I
was like with them I was in the same
room as them I was like [ __ ] kissing
table just like this like you know I
didn't even think about it and so I was
like starstruck after the fact you know
did you did was that a big catalyst for
you did that open up a lot of doors for
you after that um yes and now I got I
got a lot of hate you know Big Bang has
like like the biggest fan base oh dude
Korean fandom is [ __ ] insane insane
so I was getting like people were like
how dare you kiss him we're gonna find
you and like [ __ ] I know I didn't
[ __ ] but then I guess once he started
like looking at my profile and Instagram
and they saw that I you know had a kid
and was like married and stuff they they
were like okay oh it's just a job
oh she you know it's not a big deal
Korean fandom is [ __ ] insane like
back in the day like I remember when I
used to listen to a lot of Korean music
certain celebrities had to date on Lolo
because if they found out their favorite
male or even female celebrity was dating
somebody they would get death threats
like will [ __ ] find you in care as if
they want you yeah [ __ ] losers
you want it's it's create they're kind
of like I'm you know I'm generalized I'm
only talking about this very weird
sub-sect there's a lot of people like oh
yeah I got like so much love to like I
got a huge I oh I got a huge fan base
from that like people you know saw me
and they you know thought it was like
pretty and stuff and then they followed
my page and they liked what I was about
and so like I got tons of followers on
it cuz I got a wonder like I just want
to talk to some of these dudes and
obviously they're not in the right mind
state and this like a small percentage
of them is just like so so what was
gonna happen when you meet them they
were gonna fall in love with you yeah
who are you you [ __ ] sack of [ __ ]
it's just like it yeah it's weird like I
guess wouldn't win girls especially get
into that like fantasy area you know
they become so obsessed and so like that
you have like a thing made up in their
minds that who's your fantasy person is
a young person younger person again I
remember my first ever fantasy person
was [ __ ] Luke Skywalker when I saw
that you know and I just remember that's
like the first ever like movie crush
that I has and I was just like oh my god
I remember like I would go to like
naptime and kindergarten kindergarten
first grade and it would be not time and
I just go to sleep and I'd be like I
hope I dream about like yo I've never
heard anybody talk about Luke Skywalker
that way yeah I was weird it was I mean
it was funny I mean I don't know is that
was like my first one and then I just
like never like followed the Star Wars
fandom after that you just like Mark
Hamill like you just like Luke Skywalker
yeah I guess that's [ __ ] crazy yeah
cuz like that I once when I went to UM I
was in k-town and it was his group
called
DBSK bong bong cheney and one of the
this is when they split up but one of
the guys came to perform inside like
this this square in k-town or some [ __ ]
and this was my first account of seeing
hardcore fan
she was there was it was an outdoor mall
and there's this escalator going up but
she wanted to see him as much to fit it
and then when she saw him walk out
as the escalators going up she just
starts bawling she loved him so much
yeah and I just couldn't wrap my head
around it I'm like why the [ __ ] are you
crying what is going on in there that
happened so often like you see people
crying when they you know see they're
like idols or whatever all the time and
all the shake it is like that it's like
they just get so overwhelmed with
emotion you know just finally meeting
this or seeing this person in real life
that they've like fantasized for so long
you know and they they've developed like
a deep emotional connection with you
know obviously it's one-sided but like
especially you know like with
celebrities and stuff there shit's all
out there for everyone you know so they
know everything about them they know all
of their personal life so it's easier in
a way to like make that like fantasy in
your head because like you know what he
likes would you cry about then like if
you met them right now I don't you know
what I'm like really not into like I
don't follow like celebrities I don't I
don't you don't have I got the idol
cuz for me originally it was Bill Cosby
until he became a rapist that guy like a
[ __ ] until I all the evidence came
out I was like oh [ __ ] maybe I should
have said anything yeah I don't know I
guess I you know I have really I have to
put some thought into that I don't have
someone that I really like look up to I
just kind of like I mean yeah I I feel
like I just don't I don't like to focus
on like celebrities or like you know
famous people or you know obviously
music is big celebrity was but there's
like I guess for me I would have like if
I met Dave Chappelle yeah like I I I
wouldn't say I idolized him but he's
somebody who I see us as a stand-up
comic as I don't even say someone who's
very philosophical but the way that he
thinks and he presents his material I
know that no matter how hard I work I
will never get to his level so meeting
somebody like that even though I know
that I'm not gonna get to his level of
comedy just being around that makes me
just I probably wouldn't cry but if he
shook my hand I might not shower for
like a couple
well I guess this actually happened to
me a few days ago you know a few days
ago like a few months ago I was actually
talking about this with my girlfriend
Kimmie and we were driving up to LA
she's visiting me from Canada and we
were driving up to LA and we were
talking about like how it must be weird
for you know celebrities musicians like
anyone you know saddest to meet their
fans when their fans get all crazy you
know and like you know especially those
that cry you know freak out and it's
like man like I just I wouldn't I don't
have it in me to do that if I saw
someone famous or someone that like I
know and that it like I like what they
do or whatever I wouldn't like faze me
to like freak out or even like bother
them or go up to them or anything you
know it's just kind of like my
personality Who I am for sure I don't
know if I would come up and approach
them just because I want to give them
their personal space yeah but I felt
like I got what you're saying like still
would you feel like oh my god like
emotional or whatever yeah if I saw Dave
Chappelle dude I definitely would try to
have him spit on me or something like
yeah spit in my face so I know what it
feels like just maybe I got a little bit
of your [ __ ] talent dude yeah I I
don't know I just don't go like I've
just I I guess I because I have a son
now especially I really just try to like
focus on myself and like myself and him
and and you know growing as a mother and
like trying to be the best that it can
be for him in general so I don't really
like pay attention to anything I don't
even like to use my social media as much
anymore because you know it's just
constantly like taking my attention away
from him and and like bringing my
attention to like oh I want to do what
she's doing or like why can't I do that
or like you know and so I took a break
from Instagram for a while actually and
like it was amazing like I like barely
go on now I post but I don't scroll and
stuff yeah I mean here's the interesting
thing about that right so for you and
your profession because your model right
yeah we have this this this weird
connection with with social media and
the reason why I say that is because
like I just had a conversation with my
manager about how I am as a person right
number one when I when I started doing
YouTube and social media stuff the
reason why I did it was just for one
reason it was fun
yeah I I'm a very odd type of person
where for some reason I just need to
enjoy everything that I [ __ ] do and
it is it's kind of dumb when you think
about it because no matter what you do
you're never going to fulfill everything
that you need in one task right so a lot
of the times when people they look at
career choices they go well with this
career I want to have fun I want to make
a [ __ ] ton of money I wanted to fulfill
my my soul my spirit everything it's
very uncommon that that happens with one
singular thing in your life right so
there's a lot of pieces to this puzzle
that fills in that makes the whole of
who you are and kind of fulfills these
needs so a lot of the times with me when
I when I would look at these career
things like for example on YouTube I
kept on looking towards YouTube and
these Instagram things and I start for
fun to fulfill everything that I needed
right but the fact of the matter is the
platform has changed and YouTube
Instagram Twitter all this other stuff
it stopped becoming more for fun and it
started becoming more for notoriety and
a business tool mm-hmm right yeah so in
your case I think that's like the hard
part is like where we learn how to
separate what these things are used for
like for example like Instagram
Instagram for me it used to just be a
way for me to connect with my friends my
personal friends right so I would never
really think about you know what I'm
really posting but now I have to realize
that Instagram is not a way for me to
connect with my friends and it's a way
for me to connect with my families right
like people want to see your jokes
people want to see a little bit into
your life and that's completely okay I
think the hard part is ones people like
us we we put too much thought and time
into something not knowing what it's for
mm-hmm right so for example for you it's
like well you know I want to spend time
with my kid well you you know on the
Instagram part well if you just look at
Instagram as a way to connect with the
people who support you then it it
becomes less of a stressful thing right
yeah and we start taking we stop taking
things too personally because that's
where that weird part happens where we
do take we're all human yeah you know we
see this thing is supposed to be a tool
and a way for us to connect with people
who support us but at the same time you
see this one little comment yeah yeah I
mean for me comments like I'm never I
mean even just just being in the fashion
industry in general like you have to
have thick skin
yeah I mmm you know I I was bullied in
school all throughout school and I got a
giant for what did you just kick him in
the [ __ ] face I had like seven feet
tall I know now I was I'm I was always
just a very like nice person you know
and and I you know through that like
obviously you know it hurt a lot and and
I was really upset a lot there's so many
times I saw in the bathroom by myself
like stereotypically eating lunch in the
bathroom stall by myself cuz I didn't
want to like be seen by like you know
everyone um just like spreading rumors
you know talking [ __ ] like girls always
it was always girls hello everybody this
podcast is brought to you by skill share
oh yes skill sure I'm talking about a
digital library full of teachings
teachers and on top of that my friends
most importantly knowledge that you need
and want my friends Skillshare is an
online learning community with thousands
of amazing classes covering dozens of
creative and entrepreneurial skills you
can take classes in everything from
photography and creative writing to
design productivity and more so whether
you're returning to a longtime passion
project challenging yourself to get
outside your comfort zone or simply
exploring something new Skillshare has
classes for you for me I love
photography and for obviously as well I
do video editing and Skillshare
basically has all those classes that can
look back on and if I need to find out
something about the program for example
with like Adobe Premiere I I always go
to Skillshare Skillshare has great
teachers and great lessons and the great
thing about that is and the reason why I
like products like this is because
everybody learns at a different pace so
when I was in college I kind of I guess
you could say this there was a lot of
stuff that I didn't care for and I was
learning but the great thing about
skills sure it's your learning the stuff
that you want to learn and you're doing
it at your own pace and you have this
library of information that you could
just tap from whenever you want lifelong
learning is something that you're going
to continue for the rest of your life
you'd be surprised
like for me I thought that number one
I didn't like school growing up but it
just it doesn't mean that I don't like
learning and lifelong learning is
something that's very important in skill
sure can really help you out with that
so join the millions of students already
learning on Skillshare today with a
special offer just for my listeners get
two months of Skillshare for free that's
right Skillshare is offering genius
brain listeners two months of unlimited
access to thousands of classes for free
to sign up go to Skillshare comm slash
brain again go to Skillshare dot-com
slash brain to start your two months now
that's Skillshare dot-com slash brain
you know a lot about girls being caddy
when they're young it's it's it's it's
crazy it's ridiculous
but you know it is what it is part of
growing up I guess and you know I I had
our time you know fitting in with a lot
of people because I'm like I just never
I was never like the cheerleader type I
was never like you know sporty I just
didn't have like a niche that fit with
like anyone else I was just kind of like
I had you know my few good friends and
that's all that you know I really wanted
I didn't care for the bigger thing but
um I mean like not to sound like full of
myself or anything but you know a lot of
the boys thought I was cute and a lot of
the girls didn't like that you know and
so they would just you know attack me
that way like you know spreading lies
like oh she's like a [ __ ] or whatever
you know like girls are so dumb some
girls when you spread a rumor that a
girl's a [ __ ] it just makes it more
popular doesn't make the guys want to go
away from them no she did she [ __ ]
stuck this guy's dick I'm like okay well
let me see her because I I needed to
hang out with her a lot more happy yeah
I know you know things like that but so
I I grew thick skin over that you know
growing up that way and it helped me out
in the modeling world because you know
I'm more I'm more curvy than than most
Asians especially but um models in
general like I was always in that area
where I was too skinny to be plus-sized
or too big to be like what are they
[ __ ] call it I don't know
fashion model sighs I never understood
that that that weird world right just
because number one like I've always been
a guy who just never give a [ __ ] about
how I looked because I'm almost a comic
yeah like the goofier you look the
better it was yeah almost
if you dressed up and did the stuff to
the nines it was a detriment to your
comedy right so like whenever I would
see just that somebody who just doesn't
know [ __ ] about you know that supermodel
fashion yeah when I see like girls on
the runway I'm like damn happy just
[ __ ] skinny as [ __ ] yeah well it is I
mean times are changing of course like
you know all of that it was is like old
school like way old school it that
modeling industry didn't change for like
years you know and now you know people
are changing they're adding like
straight sizes into their you know
rosters and yeah and being more lenient
on on sizes so but you know trying to
get my foot in it was always like oh
we're not you know we're not looking for
your look right now which meant like
they Asians just weren't in they there
wouldn't be work for me especially like
half Asians because I didn't even have
like the striking Asian features that
would work at the time I was just kind
of like I'm not even trying to be mad
offensive anything behind but I would
see like some you know they when they
would pick certain Asian girls or their
supermodel [ __ ] I'm like do you pick the
most goofiest looking agency in my life
I get that you know and I think that's I
don't even see Asian people look like
that like it looks like a racist drawing
of Asian person how did you find this
dude or girl that was possible that they
you know that's what they originally did
they wanted to find like someone who is
like very obviously just strikingly but
yeah like I'm talking about like somehow
they're managing to do this without
having people with these eyes yeah it's
I mean it you know it's fine it fits
their aesthetic it's you know whatever
it's what they want that um yeah I mean
like I just you know grew up not being
this not being that being too big or
being too Asian like no not Asian
whatever so I just you know just it
developed like nothing bothers me at
this point especially comment like I got
like so much yeah I get you know so many
there's always those trolls you know
that I'll try and
say [ __ ] or say dumb [ __ ] that they hope
would make you feel bad or whatever but
it doesn't yeah so like that that's
never fazed me at all what bothered me
with social media was that I started
getting not really depressed but like
really down on myself for like not doing
enough like I always felt like you know
people always tell me like you have so
much potential yup someone's potential
like why aren't you doing this aren't
you doing that I'm like yeah I get it
like you know I I can see where you're
coming from I do feel confident that
like I could do that and that's where it
got me is because like I could do that
so like why am I not doing that or like
why are all these people getting it and
I'm not and or like you know what am i
lacking or what am I not doing that's
like holding me back you know and so I
would always just scroll and just start
feeling more and more like guilty more
like kind of upset and depressed
especially with the way I looked you
know kind of look like just my body in
general um I'm you know I'm healthy I'm
a healthy weight and stuff and it's one
of those things where like it's
comparison game it's a comparison game
yeah and it's hard like even if you're
aware of it it's still like
subconsciously in your mind you know and
and the majority of people on social
media aren't aware of it and so you know
I could see how how bad it was
especially for me you know especially
after having a kid you know getting
[ __ ] stretch marks on my stomach like
that you know well it's hard because I
feel like in your case or just women in
your case in your job in your career
your value is predicated on how you look
yeah right so like how how hard is that
like it's like you you're people value
because you look a certain way around
even when it comes to Instagram people
follow you because they want to see
something yeah you know that's also
another reason why I am kind of like
trying to transition out of the fashion
world modeling world because I want to
you know I want to be booked on like a
talent not just like she fits our
aesthetic that's who we want or she's
hot like Booker you know cuz for so long
like you know
a couple years ago all I was I was just
so obsessed on on my measurements my
weight my skin like I get like there's a
point where you have to like care for
yourself but like to the point where I
was like measuring myself every morning
like it was just like so unhealthy you
know I just not do that yeah I mean and
it's just and like even it's like I wake
up one morning and like there's like a
couple like centimeter difference I
would be like stressed as [ __ ] you know
and obviously that stress those things I
woke up and then I gained some weight
I'm like that's life now and I'm so much
happier you know like I've kind of like
given up on on that and it's it's kind
of one of those things now where it's
like you know if you want to book me the
way I am then great if you don't if you
don't like me cuz I am like a couple
inches bigger than what you want and
like there's why don't I don't care yeah
like it's it's not something I'm like
actively trying to go after anymore and
this is where I bring up with you know
it's hard because like even for you like
me you probably understand this about
yourself a lot in the past stuff that
you went through when you were a kid is
start to seep out into you as an adult
like how you view yourself right right
having to deal with this whole thought
of okay well because I looked a certain
way I got bullied so because now I don't
look this way I can't book gigs so every
has to do with the based on how you look
rather than who you are as a person
yeah and that's the hard part with your
job right because no is really I think
like from what I hear it's modeling is
one of those things too if they don't
really have rapport with you it's just
it's one of those things where who you
are doesn't matter is more like we just
want you to look a certain way and do
that walk and then write what you want
me to get the [ __ ] out right yeah and so
I think when you when people start to
come of age they just get tired of that
[ __ ] yeah totally because as you get
older things change a lot and the fact
that your career your life line is based
on something that you can't control
right it's a very hard thing to [ __ ]
deal with yeah totally um you know
that's why I see a lot of girls - like a
lot of my personal friends they won't
say they're not not that close to me but
I you know I follow them on Instagram
you know we met a few
but every time I see them their [ __ ]
lips get bigger yeah they have an
injection here they had this and that
which listen yo I understand the
argument behind it right it's you know
it's my face my body I'll do over a
hundred percent right I'm just saying
for me as somebody who's known you like
you look like a [ __ ] Picasso painting
are you like I'm shocked and then like
you know it looks great it looks good
and you know people gas it up and yeah
if you think you look fine and you look
great that's cool but I'm also allowed
to be freaked out by you when I see your
face it's been stung by a thousand bees
I've been guilty you know of wanting to
you know get lip injections or whatever
like but that that so when like when I
started thinking about that that's where
I caught myself I was like you know
that's at that point I was just like
heavily into social media like every day
looking at the guy I needed the
perception you're like okay so in order
to book jobs I need to do this I needed
like get lip injections I need to like
make my face more like you know yeah and
so like when I started thinking about
that and I started like I kind of like
caught myself and I was like like no you
know like but that's why everyone's
doing it also because they have the same
you know thing and the girls you know
cycle and it sucks too cuz like some
some of these people that I know like I
said get lip injections and I was like
you had big lips already you look like a
maniac you know but it's there on social
media yeah they their value of themself
is based on how they look because of
sometimes a lot of the times because how
other people value that right so people
just don't understand like even my mom
like if I remember one time she said oh
like should I choose I want to get rid
of some of this isn't that and I
literally told a straight-up I was like
if you do that should I won't talk to
you why was it because your your I don't
know how important it is to her right
and and she's not she's very whatever
she's like that Korean lady that wears
the visors the [ __ ] yeah big-ass [ __ ]
leather shoes and the you know the
projects that's the mom that I know
that's the mom that I love that's the
mom that I think is beautiful to the
nines right and so like for her when I
told it I was like well think about it I
guess if you if you're asking my opinion
about it and when I told her was like I
growing to love the face that you have
like
this is my mom and you want to change
things about yourself that you already
know it's gonna change constantly it's
gonna change like it's going to happen
and I don't want her to feel like you
you are always trying to grab time time
doesn't give a [ __ ] yeah right it's
gonna ravage you either way you just
have to understand that you're gonna
love yourself in your career has nothing
to do with your looks
right like you have a loving husband you
have kids who love you you know don't
worry about that [ __ ] yeah you're right
hamish super [ __ ] cute but it's it's
it's weird because it's I I've seen this
trend now constantly online where it's
not it used to be this thing of
self-love right and so self-love was
basically encapsulated in this concept
of love the stuff that you hate about
yourself because somebody out there
loves it and you should be the first one
to love it now now that concept of
self-love is slowly changing into well
you should be able to change whatever
you want you're with yourself if you
have the money because it's your body
like you what the [ __ ] did this change
hat yeah it's such an odd concept for me
and I don't know why it bothers me so
much and that's the thing that I've
actually was thinking about yesterday I
was taking a [ __ ] I was like why don't
why does it bother me when I see
somebody change something about their
body and I I and I and I can't wrap my
head around I don't know why it's none
of my [ __ ] business you know I I
think I kind of get what you're coming
from and I feel like it's because you
know that they did that because at some
point in their life they felt and like
just not good enough right yeah like and
something made them feel that way and
maybe that's what angers you like I I it
frustrates me at that point too or like
I have known people that have done that
you know to their bodies and and I mean
like I said you do what you want to do
if it makes you more confident than
great like I'm not here to like shame
anyone for doing anything but like you
know that there was a point where they
thought to themselves like this isn't
pretty
yeah and it's from what they've seen you
know like you know social media or
whatever and they felt like they were
not you know sometimes for me it feels
like they're putting money into like
this bank that has a hole under at the
bottom like this
Jarre that's just the whole number they
keep throwing money into it right it's
just it's not there's no end there's no
end game to this hmm like you're not
gonna be time yeah you're not going to
and you think that by the time that you
get older you're like well I just wanted
to keep you know the way I look as long
as possible
well eventually you know that's gonna
run out and when it runs out I have yet
to see the person that when it ran out
they were completely okay with how they
looked as they were all yeah and it's
just if if I saw that Norm maybe I'd be
able to understand it but I always see
was the opposites that they try to keep
on keep holding on to this random youth
or whatever they think is beautiful or
whatever society or social media tells
you that you're beautiful and you try to
mold yourself into that constantly and
eventually you just give up and you're
just sad yeah and it sucks right so it's
like well what what is self-love then
right like that's that's the part to it
like are we are we really just
transforming this definition of self
left to fit what we want now mm-hmm
right and I get scared cuz like Alyssa
if I have a daughter and I see her doing
that type of [ __ ] that [ __ ] would
[ __ ] tear me apart me I don't want
her to think that she has to look a
certain way for her to feel good about
herself yeah and that's the hard part
you know yeah totally my um my little
sister she's 12 she's modeling - oh sure
she's always had it in her like even
when she's a toddler she'd just pose and
like walk you know stir her stuff she
just loves it and she's doing really
well she's like with only models she
books Nike every weekend
she's like working more than me you know
yeah and there has been times where I've
seen her like look at the other asian
girls that are like on her status that
are booking jobs and you know they look
different some of them are half asian
she's you know she's she's half Korean
happy enemies so she you know has a very
striking Asian like she's very beautiful
yeah but you know there's there's times
where I can see it like in her she won't
say you know she won't say it she's very
like stubborn very prideful she's like
crazy person but she I can I can just
see it in her you know like I can see in
her face when she's looking on Instagram
or whatever or like when she hears that
so-and-so booked the job or so-and-so
it's getting popular in Korea or you
know
all this stuff and I just like
constantly have to be there to remind
her like that's not who you are like you
have something unique that's you know
yeah that's you you know don't don't
feel bad about it you know you don'tyou
shouldn't be like everyone else that's
why you're booking jobs because you you
know you are you're unique in your
person you don't want to look like
everyone else
you know and so it's it's like a you
know kind of like a full-time job for me
as a big sister to keep reminding her
yeah my mom does too my mom is also a
model and she you know was our age and I
should run in the family my cousin's
models yeah they're all yeah it's it's
pretty awesome
but um luckily you know she has two
people on her side who are familiar with
industry and like we can like save her
from a lot of that like you know
self-loathing and kind of so how did you
deal with that part when you kind of
were going through this whole phase
where you wanted to get injections you
were just constantly judging yourself um
well luckily that was you know probably
like within the last year so I was old
enough to kind of be like wait a minute
yeah what the [ __ ] am I thinking you
know I I just realized like I don't know
it was a battle it's like there was
nothing really that you know I didn't
like stop and say like you're perfect
the way you are kind of thing it was it
was one of those things where I just had
to like learn to accept it like I still
look in the mirror like and I still see
things that I'm just liking some stuff
that you hate about yourself then it's
it sounds ridiculous I mean there's
nothing that I hate about myself but you
pick on things that I pick on it like
it's like my the shape of my face like I
have it what the [ __ ] are you saying
it's crazy it goes that deep though like
it's it's no like it's I don't want to
talk about it well the reason why is
like I'm gonna I'm just gonna bring up a
point your point but I just want to know
what what don't you like about this you
the face this is my good side right the
right side of my face is my good side
and the left side of my face like it's
all so pretty but like it's not as good
as my good side and
it's it's different you know when you
look at yourself in the mirror for long
enough exactly but to me it's like I you
know there was there was times where I
was obsessing over it you know like what
is it that you don't like about the
right to left
it's my jaw my jawline so on the right
side it goes up like it's like nice and
sleek and on the left side it kind of
like goes down a little and then it goes
up so it's like just very like it's it's
stupid it's so [ __ ] stupid and it
doesn't bother me you know but they
should notice one thing yeah something
that I noticed but it's you know
whatever like it I know people don't
notice it's not a big deal at all and
for a while I was very ashamed of my
stretch marks like I felt really bad
about them that's a hard thing to deal
with though it is
especially you know when you're in the
industry you see all these models that
have babies and they don't have stretch
marks you're like what the [ __ ] you know
what do they do and like I was like
lathering my belly with oil every day
every morning just constantly non-stop
and then you know I read that it's like
it's genetic a lot of it is genetic like
if your mom had them then you're gonna
have them too like there's nothing you
can like no oils can that can fix it you
know and so like that's that's when I
started accepting it so I was like
before I read about that you know the
genetic thing I was like man like what
did I do wrong like how did I [ __ ] up so
bad how did I let this happen to me kind
of thing and then I'm like once I
started learning that like there was
nothing I could have done like its
nature it happens then I you know was
like okay like this is my body now and
it's normal and like everyone has this I
mean not everyone like there's some
lucky ones that don't but if you do then
like it's whatever it's a part of life
you know I'm still beautiful like that's
why I posted that you know yeah
Instagram pictures yeah you know that
really hit home for me because you know
there was you know people in my life
that were like if you get stretch marks
like you're gonna you're gonna regret it
like do whatever you can to make it stop
otherwise like it's gonna suck you know
I [ __ ] you up a little bit it [ __ ]
me up a lot and so and then I got angry
I was like you know what [ __ ] you like
this is [ __ ] like this is life this
is natural I'm not gonna be ashamed of
it you know and then that kind of gave
me courage to like you know post about
like
about you know that photo that I had I
asked Michael the photographer to you
know get like give me the untouched
photos because I you know I spent some
time looking at it and then I was like
it doesn't look bad like this there's
nothing wrong here at all you know and
then I realized like you don't ever see
models posting especially like mom dolls
posting you know bikini photos with
their you stretched myself usually
they're retouch was just fine you know
it's it's part of the game
things are always to be touched you know
in the industry but I was just I just
was like one day I was like [ __ ] it I'm
gonna posted and then I found that quote
and I was like this is like the best
[ __ ] quote ever you know there are
people out there guys especially that
think that way and and put even more
stress you know on their the mother of
the children that is totally [ __ ]
and this is just like certain sect of
men that you know they're they're also
victim to like the whole social media
thing to you know because a lot of
people put their best foot forward and
they they project it as reality right
like this is how I look every day this
is my outlook on life every day and it
becomes to the point where they start to
believe their own [ __ ] [ __ ] like
I know a lot of these [ __ ] too
late
they stunt like they got [ __ ] right yeah
they dressed to the nines they got the
most expensive [ __ ] it's like
[ __ ] I know how much money yeah
yeah yeah because you don't make
anywhere near as much money as I do
right so I know for a fact that you
broke is [ __ ]
but they want to show these kids that
they're they're they're living life you
know the best way possible yeah and it's
so [ __ ] dumb yeah no I I think it's
cool because for you to aspire to show
kids to aspire to be something right but
I'm not telling people to put like
emotional post and you know you know try
to clickbait these kids into drama and
[ __ ] like yeah but kids should be
smarter enough or they should be a
certain amount of information for people
no like you know this isn't real yeah
like this is this is some [ __ ] for you
to look at because it looks nice but
yeah people got stretch marks and some
of the funniest [ __ ] guys are like
the most sloppiest dirtiest looking
dudes and they see a woman they walk by
they're like yo you know what I would
[ __ ] do with that absolutely nothing
[ __ ] sludge mom
yeah nobody would touch you you
disgusting son of a [ __ ] like that that
even thought that that crossed your mind
is odd to me because you would literally
not know what to do with it there's a
funny too because like I was um I was
telling with my friend and there's a
girl she got like a huge fat ass right
now how I asked him my whole life he was
like so what would you do with that I
look the most like I have no idea I
wouldn't know what does she would drown
me in that ass and I was like I got no
idea I have no idea what I would do with
that just lies with you was you know
like like I and I the reason why bring
up like what what you hate about
yourself is because I would have never
ever ever noticed that stuff right yeah
and we're always our worst critic right
and we always look at [ __ ] like oh man
like I don't like this about myself this
about that and say yeah nobody does dude
they just they just see you as a whole
package right in and if in fact you want
people to judge you for stuff outside of
your looks then it also has to be
reflected in how you behave in how you
treat yourself too right yeah so it's
like you can't expect somebody else to
look past your looks when the thing that
you think about the most is your looks
and how you appear all the [ __ ] yeah so
we're also a reflection of how we treat
ourselves yeah I always tell these kids
to it's like yo man they go well like I
make this joke constantly and it's junk
because it's real [ __ ] idea I was fat
people would tell me I was fat but then
I had like this odd concept of who I was
as a person man you're fat I'm not fat
yeah Chris Farley is fat I'm not fat
dude I'm fit like I could play
basketball you know that's what I would
think and then it just took merry old
one day to look at me and be like bro
you're fat now like do what you're a
[ __ ] you know I didn't like it you you
know you're not like you're just
unhealthy you know and I just didn't
realize that type of stuff because I
kind of like somehow just tricked myself
into believing like I'm profession
dryers keeps shrinking my shirts bro I
don't know what's going on yeah okay so
I had like that ops of opposite prom
where I just gas myself so much that I
didn't even realize how I looked as a
human being you know in terms of just
not you know yeah health and also I just
look really scrubby
and I just had no [ __ ] clue and I
think it's because growing up for me I
was always be I was always able to
circumvent how I looked or everything
else how just because I had a mouthpiece
I could talk really well so I wanted to
talk to women yeah it was a it was an
uphill battle but because I spoke really
well you know it was a lot easier for me
than other dudes that couldn't write so
that was something that I always
depended on so I never had a rely on how
I looked too much like to a certain
extent but you know after a while I
think that was something that kind of
came to my aid because I just don't care
as much like when I walk outside the
first thing I think i merit Mariel even
knows this about me - she goes you don't
ever look at a mirror before you leave
the house like you just don't care yeah
yeah like I what's gonna happen if I go
outside and make somebody looks at me
and they go that guy looks trashy it's
like you're probably right bro on about
my life yeah you know because Mariel was
taught to at a young age that her aunt
used to always say this to her even if
you go out to a grocery store make sure
that you are done up because somebody
could be your next husband or something
yeah yeah and I feel like a lot of girls
are taught that ya know from a young age
not necessarily like the husband thing
but like you know people treat you
differently the way you look like it is
and it is true and I mean it's there's
nothing bad and you know about caring
about the way you look when you leave
the house there was sure um but you know
to the point where I was there was a
point in my life you know in my early
20s where I would never leave the house
without makeup on even if I was like
going to the car oh I have a friend in
high school that I know now I don't know
what she looks like without makeup yeah
when we went camping that [ __ ] came out
the tent with makeup are you doing yeah
I mean it's just a thing like you know
you become so insecure without your
makeup on and and when you wear makeup
that often even more like when you when
you're just constantly wearing makeup
and like you know you have this the way
you like to look yeah when you take it
all off at the end of the day it's a
huge difference always you're like holy
[ __ ] like I would never leave the house
what makeup because you're not used to
it because you always look at yourself
with makeup on and after I had my son
honestly like I didn't have time for
makeup I was like [ __ ] it I don't got
eyebrows I don't care like it's just
like you know it really put a lot of
things in perspective like what's
important
yeah exactly and you know now you know
obviously not everyone's gonna have kids
to help them yeah you know you know
realize these things so I you know try
to actively do that like sometimes I'll
make posts without makeup sometimes just
kind of like trying to like put little
things here and there to like remind
people like hey like this is normal too
you know like I don't wear makeup all
the time like I today's the first time I
put makeup on in like a week
you know just feel like you know certain
things that I'm doing like if I'm going
to a job or if I'm like you know like a
lot of my friends too when they stop
wearing makeup as much their skin got
better - yeah I totally just do it so
much better just like yeah breathe you
know like its natural yeah I mean
there's people that wear makeup all the
time and they just take care of their
skin you know and that's fine but I also
noticed that like when I stopped wearing
makeup as much I learned to love my
natural face like I my eyebrows are very
light you know I always have to draw
them in when I do my makeup but you know
when I go for a week without merit
wearing makeup it's it's normal to me
and I'm like oh like my eyebrows are bad
like you know you can still see you know
even if I'm not wearing makeup really
[ __ ] yeah totally totally and I think um
you know I see a lot of people on
Instagram models especially doing like
the whole no makeup challenge like you
know it's a [ __ ] challenge it is
today's society it is like for a lot of
girls especially you know it is a
challenge I've seen sighs like 12 year
old girls like ten year old girls just
makeup and dressed up to the nines I'm
like [ __ ] where the [ __ ] are you going
barely read yeah that to me is like I'll
see that on like he's no more and it
scares me yeah it's like man when I was
like when I was 12 I was I don't know
what the [ __ ] I was wearing like
Skechers and like [ __ ] yeah gym clothes
and [ __ ] I don't know I'm like and I I
see it - like I see some of my friends
like they got kids and it's not my place
to say anything but you know what I see
like a like a [ __ ] three-year-old
girl with makeup eyeshadow everything
and then walking out in heels and [ __ ]
and I'm like yo bro your daughter looks
like a hooker bro your [ __ ] daughter
looks like she sucks dick for a living
oh my god
so just just to put it out there but I
think it's it [ __ ] me up because you
know I'm not a parent but I think like
that's the beginning of house a girl
starts to perceive herself yeah as I'm
only pretty when I do this instead of
saying makeup is a tool in accessory for
when I want to feel extra special yeah
and it stops becoming a state and starts
become a standard of who you are right
this is Who I am as a standard that's
I'm saying like when I saw that girl
come out the tent when we went camping I
was like yo this is the first time I'm
gonna see this [ __ ] without makeup she
came out makeup I was like it's 6:00
a.m. in the morning that means you woke
up at 5:00 to do your face are you
[ __ ] insane yeah like I wanted to
take her face and dunk it in some flames
just to take shits I mean there's those
people I know in relationships that you
know will spend the night with her
boyfriend or whatever wake up in the
morning before he wakes up either make
up get back in bed like I saw yeah and
you know but it's just the thing like
it's just how society like makes it
normal I mean if you was somebody that
doesn't like your normal ass face maybe
you really shouldn't be with it exactly
that's that's really another thing and I
think a lot of a lot of women learn that
as they get older yeah
just takes time but it's also up to us
you know especially influential people
that know that these are issues you know
to like make it known that it's okay to
not wear makeup and like kind of like
the whole like real self-love thing you
know you appreciate yourself for who you
are you know and it's it's such a it's
it's such an uphill battle especially
when you're you know you have one post
in a sea of Instagram model posts you
know and you just hope that you know
some people see it and and it helps them
you know think even for a second like oh
yeah maybe like you know what's twisting
what's gonna be your next move then
outside of modeling then since it seems
like it's something that you know you
kind of grew up with is what you're
doing and you want to do things maybe
outside of that yeah I really like to
get into acting oh really
yeah I I was always been acting that was
actually my first thing before modeling
I was always in like drama clubs and
school plays and like all these things
I had a lot of fun with that and then
modeling kind of just you know became
the main thing because it was it was
what I could do like it was just he was
looking back I mean your mom did it your
family I got scouted when I was 14 in an
Outback Steakhouse bathroom
like the lady she founded a one of the
popular agencies in San Diego that just
recently moved up to here and I was
living in Germany at the time I grew up
in Germany so I was just back in San
Diego visiting family and I got came out
the bathroom stall was washing my hand
there's this like lady sitting there
like looking me up and down and I'm just
kind of like oh she's like hey how old
are you interested modeling and I was
like yeah but I live in Germany so you
know never really did anything about
that but when I moved back to San Diego
I was like I'm in Germany shot yeah my
dad was in the military so oh [ __ ] um I
yeah I was born in San Diego I moved to
Boston when I was four for four years
and then I went to North Carolina for
about six years and then I moved to
Germany for about like eight and a half
years you know yeah I'm gonna move back
to San Diego when I was 20 21
hey you a jet setter you lived all over
for a bit too yeah I was um I you know
after I moved back to San Diego after I
think was after the big bang job whatnot
I got a lot of followers and then my
agency in Thailand messaged me on
Instagram and was like hey are you
interested in coming out here for a
couple months doing like you know the
whole modeling thing and staying in the
model house and it was like why not like
heck yeah you know and so they're like
great you're coming out here in two
weeks and I was like oh [ __ ] okay you
know I didn't know anyone in Thailand I
didn't know the agency I was just kind
of like just did it you know cuz I'm so
used to traveling like yeah fine and
that was an experience for me you know
kind of just the first time I was really
like on my own like working modeling do
my own thing exploring a new country and
I lived there for three months and then
came back and then did the same thing in
Hong Kong the next year for another
three months and just kind of like did
my my time overseas and stuff and I
I'm still with agencies I still get like
direct bookings like oh yeah people an
out for a job or something every now and
then but um yeah I was it was really
awesome and also you know another thing
that kind of kick-started my embracing
my Asian background you know so you
never really identified yourself as
asian girl or no yeah never like well
going way back to the Big Bang comment
after that is when I was like like
Koreans are cool man nut not saying that
I didn't think they were cool before but
I just wasn't like you know aware of
like the Korean beauty Korean fashion
just like you know I love the food of
course like you know I love my family
and I wasn't like a selfie or anything I
don't want to not be Korean I just
didn't really like identify with it you
know um but after you know BIGBANG I
kind of just really got into all of it I
started reading about Korean beauty I
started doing my makeup like a little
bit more like natural or more like dewy
you know how like the crayons yeah you
do it like and then I noticed that I
just started embracing a lot more of it
you know I don't know and then going to
Asia of course I feel like Korean the
Korean like aesthetic the Korean look
all over Asia people like want that like
they all follow k-beauty they follow
kpop it's like just kind of like what's
in over there and so while it was over
there I just got into it even more you
know cuz everyone was into it and so it
just kind of like really it's
interesting how you know we we don't
even realize like how deeply really dark
culture is in us right until like
there's something that sparks it yeah
really don't know what it is like I I
never really considered myself like a
Korean Korean person until her like
Mario's family and her Sheila you're
pretty [ __ ] Korean yes Korean as a
[ __ ] yes yeah and you know just cuz I
just never really spoke the language
unless it was to my parents right but
there's something about me growing up
and I never thought that being able to
speak Korean and when I have kids in the
future I want them to be able to speak
Korean to I didn't know how important
that was gonna be to me
because I feel like people when they
come to the states or when they live
here they think that you're blending in
is how you become an American and I
think the opposite is true it's wearing
a kind of embrace your culture and
that's what allows you to be an American
like what I love like thank you so much
you know it's kind of insane yeah I I
you know there's a point where I still
try to learn Korean I mean my hum and he
talks to me she only talks to me in
Korean and all throughout my life I
never understood a [ __ ] word she says
just like oh yeah you know I I would
pick up on a little things yeah you know
you know I was just trying to feed me or
telling me to do things I would do it
and I wouldn't realize that I understood
what she said if she said it again I
probably wouldn't understand it like
it's one of those things you know and so
now I'm like trying to teach myself the
language just so I can teach my son yeah
like his dad is Brazilian Portuguese so
he speaks Portuguese with him all the
time
yeah only ever Portuguese and I speak
English with him but you know I'll add
little Korean things here like little
words that I know you know and it just
kind of just makes me feel bad cuz I'm
just like man I really wish like I could
give him more of the culture because
he's only quarter Korean yeah at this
point but I want him to like embrace it
you know I want him I don't want it I
don't want him to lose it you know yeah
to that point where I just I want to try
and keep it involved yeah I mean that's
gonna be in a reflection of yourself and
how much you care about it and how much
you want to do it so it's like life for
me so my my my girlfriend she could
speak Japanese Korean Mandarin and
English right so yeah so she I wanted to
she wants people on how to speak
Japanese but because I don't practice on
a daily basis so I took Japanese on high
school and then after high school I
learned it on my own but I got like 50%
of it no actually 90% of it but the
thing that frustrates her sometimes I
think is that because I learned it if
she speaks to me Japanese I know
everything she's saying yeah and I I
just respond her in English Yeah right
so like I'm at that point words if I she
wants our kids to know Japanese and
Korean if she makes this she have no
she's not well she's like a person
Japanese she found out through with 23
yeah
and so her uh so for me now it's my job
to learn
language so I could pass it on because
you know the household is where it's
always gonna be at yeah so if it's not
reiterated there it kind of [ __ ] it all
up so it's like oh [ __ ] man I gotta lose
this [ __ ] - like memorize lines and
[ __ ] learn Japanese son of a [ __ ]
man so hard yeah but I think like
growing up myself I like now I really
wish that I spoke Korean too like I feel
like I would have just opened my
opportunities like buy so much more you
know then now I mean even when I go to
Korea for a job or something everyone
always tells me like if you spoke Korean
like game over yeah like you know learn
it learn it and I'm like I do learn it
but it's [ __ ] hard like you know I I
just I don't know like I try to
implement it date into my daily life but
like there's no one I speak Korean to
unless I go to like freaking Zion market
or something or like that's it you know
move to LA everybody scream everybody
scream you pick that [ __ ] up fast man
just come over here you just talk to me
at Muriel Korean all day and you just
write notes all day it's what you have
to do yeah but definitely teaching your
kids multiple languages is sort it for
sure I even like when I was still with
you know my ex I was picking it I was
learning Portuguese cuz I was like I
want him I want to be able to talk to my
son yeah learning Portuguese and I don't
know [ __ ] okay he curses at you you
little son of a [ __ ] things like that
well that's that's basically it for the
podcast our in and that's really it yeah
thank you for coming through thanks for
having me this is my first podcast ever
oh really you don't know the park
anymore no spiders just all chitchat and
talking do people get to know you as a
person
kind of like twitch - except I'm talking
to us like someone in person oh so what
can they find you uh you can find me at
yg moon twitch.tv slash yg moon yeah I I
actually stopped for a while well I
started it and it was really is going
really good but I just couldn't get a
schedule down because I have my son yeah
you know I don't want to string with him
and you know there's a shame too often
and and so I you know I don't think i've
streamed in like almost like a month and
a half or two months
but I still yeah my my streams actually
blew up in Korea oh really like the last
time I did was a cooking stream and I
was like making pasta or whatever just
talking drinking wine and someone posted
it on Naver like they took gifts of my
of my stream and posted it on Naver and
then like 20 other websites and Korea
posted it and it just got like hundreds
of that is what it is to be a pretty
person did I tell you that if I did a
cooking stream nobody watch that [ __ ]
dude cooking food I don't know what it's
like to be pretty dude sometimes mad
like it's like it's so funny cuz like I
always clown my friend Gio about this
year so we were having this like
heart-to-heart conversation and she's
just like yeah you know like people were
kind of talking about like stuff that
they went through when they were kids
right she goes yes you know like a lot
of people thinks it's like you know you
know pretty girls get it the easiest and
I just go but you know it's so
interesting because the world does treat
pretty people way differently and you
know we see the good side but there's
also that bad side too just because you
know that jealousy factor is so [ __ ]
huge because they'll say some [ __ ] like
all the lines of oh she's pretty but I
bet you she's a [ __ ] yeah she's pretty
funny because I always see this quote on
Facebook that's like oh best friends
you know when best friends talk I can't
remember [ __ ] right now but basically
along the lines of like best friends now
would look back and say oh when I first
saw you I thought you were a [ __ ] kind
of thing they're like oh yeah that's so
funny but I'm just like no like I was
friends with someone not like best
friends are good friends but we were
becoming friends and we you know we were
at the bar drinking one night and she's
like going off about like yeah when I
first saw you I thought you were a [ __ ]
like all this stuff like I didn't want
to even talk to you and I was like [ __ ]
you you don't even know me what kind of
person are you you know just kind of
like I don't want to hang out with you
like I get it but like I mean she was
just going in on it you know and I was
just like because a lot of the things
you know [ __ ] we're gonna wrap this back
but you know the weird thing so let me
just tell you the story about in college
so when I was in college no one I had a
girlfriend my first year do you be fat
kid whatever but I I don't know what it
was about the way that I grew up like
yeah I [ __ ] like looking at pretty
girls or [ __ ] whatever my you know fat
ass fat titties whatever you know normal
aspect yeah you know teenage kid but
something about either the way that I
was raised or whether it was because the
way my mom raised me the way somebody
looked didn't really as much as other
people affect how I treated somebody
right and it was just because I think I
I started to grow up and realize when I
was a kid um I when you're younger you
you'd like to hang out with people based
on how they make you feel or the the
social currency that you get from yeah
right so I'm in this group I become the
cool guy makes me feel good whatever
slowly I you know probably when I was
like 17 or so I just started saying [ __ ]
that [ __ ] I don't need that stuff any
much yeah I just want to be around good
people no matter if they were different
if they were dweeby nerdy some of them
were thugs I just wanted to be around
people that had my back all the time
right and so because of that I think I
had this mentality of a [ __ ] what you
look like who are you as a person yeah
so there was this chick she was uh she
was like a high school cheerleader or
whatever one and this one went to UCR
and when we're in the dorm I do number
one anything she was that [ __ ] cute
but she had a really nice body I think
that's why everybody [ __ ] with it right
so every time she'll walk into a room
guys come in how are you doing today and
every time she says something that
wasn't even [ __ ] funny uh you know
and you know I had a girlfriend who I
thought was the world to me so I could
give a [ __ ] like matter so one day we're
chilling you know in the dorm we're all
hanging out and she just looks at me she
goes why don't you like me and I was
like what what do you I don't dislike
you yeah she was yeah you don't like me
and I'm like so you you kind of like
just walk by
you don't really like talk to me or
anything like you talk to everybody else
and I was like no I talked to you the
same amount as I talk to everybody else
I don't know what you're talking about
there's people I talk to more because
I'm
I'm growing closer to them like we
connect but I don't I don't get what
you're saying I'll say we'll give me a
give me an example she goes well like
yesterday like I wasn't I was in the
hallway you know where I was chatting it
up I said hi to you you said hi and you
walked by and I was like yeah so what
did I do
yeah right she was nothing you just like
don't really talk to me and I'm like oh
I know why now it's because you're used
to people giving you special attention
that's why you're used to a guy coming
up to you laughing at everything that
you're saying they just think that
you're the [ __ ] funniest [ __ ] on
earth what you're really not so that's
the type of typical treatment that
you're used to so when I treat you like
a normal person cuz I could give a [ __ ]
less about you and plus you really
weren't my type
you know [ __ ] no ass so you're not my
[ __ ] you know I mean so for her she she
kind of equated me treating her like a
normal person as somebody who just
didn't like her at all because everybody
else was trying to [ __ ] her yeah you
know I saw I was like and then you know
for her she's like well you're like the
do any fat guy you should be fawning
over me you know not really like lady
like you and I grew up differently yeah
I mean I grew up around lady with big
tits and big asses like that's why I
like you were [ __ ] flat-chested
little tiny girl it's not my [ __ ] also
you're kind of a [ __ ] yeah I think like
that's where sometimes that that that
[ __ ] attitude comes in because there
are girls like that who are used to
being treated a certain way that when
they don't receive that type of
treatment they think if they feel funny
about it right and it sucks too and
there's also this other like flip to it
where sometimes girls when they see a
pretty girl they they want to be that
girl mm-hmm right and so when they when
they see you they automatically be [ __ ]
because it makes them feel good about
themselves they go well if I look like
that I wouldn't be like or even I don't
know who you are
yeah yeah totally it's just like when
when people like you I mean I guess you
know I'm sure everyone has done it at
some point but like I just don't want to
be around that kind of negativity like
people like that they just jump to
conclusions they're like go for shitty
things like that so that's why I cut her
off but damn it you just like slice yeah
you are Koreans just like out of my life
don't look back I don't get it you're
gonna meet a lot of people like that
though even for me to like I think a lot
of people when they first meet me oh
that's kind of my fault though because
I'm very like I'm very honest and open
yeah a lot of the times I think people
get scared by that and so they kind of
an [ __ ] I'm actually completely okay
with it yes I'm just saying you're right
it's just I'm an [ __ ] to you cuz I
don't [ __ ] like you you know yeah
you're just gonna see that a lot yeah
yeah I'm just going to be a little bit
more empathetic since now it's like okay
like I could see where you're coming
from why you would think that but if
they're like that 24/7 it's kind of hard
to deal with yeah yeah I'm like I'm
generally really like nice I just was
raised to be polite all the time and
just like you know give people benefit
of the doubt and like I'm always just
Pleasant like I'm always chill and nicer
to anyone like you said doesn't matter
who they look like that's hard though
because like I said from somebody's
outside perspective they see you you're
a very beautiful woman and they're tall
giant you know and it's it's it's it's
daunting sometimes right like um when
Muriel first met geo the first thing
Muriel said constantly when we got back
home she goes wow she's really pretty
she couldn't stop saying it and I'm like
well you keep mentioning how pretty she
is she was [ __ ] beautiful right but
there is this thing when sometimes I
feel like when girls see another girl
that's just ideally beautiful it makes
them almost feel bad about themselves
yeah I get that I mean there's one look
at a [ __ ] hot there's a hot-ass dude
you know hot guys like [ __ ] ripped
jacked right I don't go home there's no
like self-esteem issue for me that
happens I think that's for a lot of guys
but for some reason when like women see
other women they just start to go home
and they start to pick things that
there's like no I don't have that type
of face I don't have long legs like her
you know when they start to feel I mean
it's totally I mean I've been guilty of
that a few times too but then I you know
I'm quick to be able to be like it's
hard though like I'm telling you man
like it's it's a mental [ __ ] game
like they say they see that thing in you
and there they go they have to they have
to almost call you a [ __ ] because it's
it's gonna just they want the
justification
like God wouldn't make her that pretty
for enough for nothing there's an
exchange she has to be a bit yeah right
it's like some of my friends who are
like my friend Yoshi right I [ __ ]
love this guy handsome [ __ ] mm-hmm off
to the Knights and I'm like I pray so
imma go she I just wish you or a [ __ ]
[ __ ] this is person I've ever had
yeah I want to hate you but I can't I
[ __ ] love you man you know I mean the
guy's such a nice [ __ ] dude yeah you
would never think that when you meet
somebody like that because you want to
think ill thoughts about them feel
better about yourself yeah yeah guys
well that ends this podcast remember
follow her on Twitch you can see her on
Instagram or whatever very wonderful
guest kind of going into the insides of
modeling and self look and you know just
all that type of [ __ ] that I know that a
lot of people go through on a daily
basis um you know models go through [ __ ]
- I yeah you know I know what it's like
just kidding but anyways we'll see you
guys next time peace